so all right so as a news guy when
you're covering stories like this
obviously you as a progressive you
believe that gay people should be equal
there should be gay NBA players and and
all that so how do you balance between
that and then the people the bible
thumpers and we're gonna get to some of
that in just a second but I want to
leave the clip i how do you decide to
present something in a somewhat fair way
when you pretty much know what you think
about it and and want to argue for
equality well I try to educate people
about their religions cuz nobody ever
reads actual books right so and I don't
want to be too denigrating etcetera
because I know a lot of people faith my
mom is a person of faith she has be
Muslim right but you know and but I love
her and I and I get that it comes from a
good place for a lot of people they just
don't actually know what's in the book
so in the same verse uh in Leviticus
that you shall not lie with a man as you
lie with a woman it also says you should
not eat shellfish and everybody's eating
shrimp lobster allergic or something and
so immediately they have this moment of
like oh my god wait am i gay but if I
does something as bad as the gays right
and they almost don't believe it and
then when they go read it they're like
oh wow why did we take the gay part and
go ballistic over it and we don't talk
about the shellfish at all why is there
no red lobster madness the leaders of
the church picking and choosing what
they want to preach about and you guys
have given me a perfect segue to our
first clip this is chris broussard on
ESPN's outside the lines earlier today I
don't agree with homosexuality I think
it's a sin as I think all sex outside of
marriage between a man and a woman is
and else he knows that he and I have
played on basketball teams together for
several years we've gone out had lunch
together we've had good conversations
good laughs together he knows where I
stand and I know where he stands I don't
you know criticize him he doesn't
criticize me and called me a bigot call
me ignorant called me intolerant and now
that I here and talking to some people
around to me there are a lot of
Christians in the NBA and they don't
want to be just because they disagree
with that lifestyle they don't want to
be viewed and called bigoted and
intolerant and things like that and
that's what else he was getting at
just like I may tolerate someone whose
lifestyle I disagree with he can
tolerate meet my beliefs and he
disagrees with my beliefs in my
lifestyle but true tolerance and
acceptance is being able to handle that
in Whitman as mature adults and not
criticize each other and call each other
names so the the LZ that he's talking
about is LZ Granderson who's an ESPN
columnist who is openly gay and I find
this clip fascinating because it goes to
what you're talking about drank about
the way people use the Bible because
he's also there's an implication in what
he's saying that somehow he his feelings
are as equal as the gay persons feelings
except only one of those two people in
this case Jason Collins or LZ Granderson
only one of those people doesn't have
equal right so it doesn't seem like it
adds up to me exactly you hit it right
on the head you know all right pretty
good I guess it's all about no it is
true I hate when people just keep on
throwing this religion into everything I
mean it's sports there should be no
religion in discussion about sports it's
a sport yeah if he's gonna complain or
anyone complain about being someone gay
and he made it equivalent as having sex
outside of marriage for a man and a
woman also so when I complain about all
those players having sex outside of
wedlock right yeah so that that's the
whole point about religion and it's
picking and choosing because if you
wanted to actually follow the rules
everybody would be guilty like
premarital sex is just as wrong in the
Bible is their big question about like
hey we had our first player in the NBA
who had premarital sex know everybody
hit me except for a degree has had
premarital sex premarital sex and post
marital sex in the NBA in right and and
that's worse right if you're following
the rules all right we have not taken
any of those people's rights away
exactly that's exactly and look you know
unfortunately a lot of people use
religion for discrimination and it's
happened throughout history so they
don't I mean look on sports are you
kidding me touching pigskin is against
the bible that's abomination so there
goes entire NFL right but they don't
choose that they don't choose a
shellfish clause they don't choose the
premarital sex or the divorce clause
they choose to discriminate against gays
they use that part of the Bible because
they want to discriminate they also use
the Bible to justify slavery yeah like
people now whitewash that like it didn't
happen but it happened right and which
is the fascinating thing because Chris
booster Broussard who obviously is black
is then using the same book that people
used against him and in the sixties when
they you know blacks could not marry
White's they use the Bible against that
whole debate also yeah yeah I want to
remind you guys that the official
outfitter of the Ruben report is bonobos
go to bonobos com use code trr 20 and
get yourself this fancy shirt